Let's go to our caller from the five or eight
area code.
Maybe a caller from the Boston area.
Caller from five 08.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hello, David.
Yes.
This is tell me from Massachusetts.
Toby, how are you?
I'm doing good.
My question to you is.
Do you think Republicans will be onboard with
abolishing the Electoral College if they lose
an election?
If if they win the popular vote, but lose
the Electoral College.
Well, so two answers to that.
First is.
Yeah, probably they'll probably very quickly
change their mind if the Electoral College
ends up hurting them.
So Republicans benefit from the Electoral
College.
We have a number of cases, including in 2016,
where the Republican candidate lost the popular
vote but won electorally.
And that's part of why Republicans defend
it.
But it's extremely unlikely to happen.
That's the reality and that many Republican
presidents have only won because of the Electoral
College.
And I mean, listen, this November is an example.
Trump is not going to win the popular vote.
The question is, did he does he eke out an
electoral victory?
So I just don't think we're going to see that
anytime soon.
I mean, maybe, you know, in four or eight
years, but certainly this year, Biden.
If I were a betting man, I would bet on Biden
winning the popular vote.
I don't know who's going to win electorally.
Yeah, because that's something I've been thinking
about.
I would think about the.
The national popular vote interstate compact
that I'm in.
I've been hoping then that is something that
gets through in the near future, even if it's
not likely because.
The Electoral College is such a broken system.
Yes, yes, so for people who don't know the
national popular vote interstate compact,
what that is, is essentially states who say.
Instead of awarding our electoral votes to
whoever wins, our state will award them to
whoever wins the national popular vote.
If you get enough states together to do that,
such that the total of their electoral votes
is 270, which is the number required for the
presidency.
You've effectively made a national popular
vote.
The legal question around it is whether some
states are not allowed to do that.
And that's an issue that's come up recently
by state constitutional law.
And obviously, you know, I'm not a lawyer.
My formal training is in podiatry.
So I would not be able to answer that.
OK, I guess we lost Toby there, Toby.
Toby had enough with me and Toby hung up.